[Musique]
une vue sur mer incomparable les pieds
dans l'eau le paradis pour la majorité
d'entre nous tout serait tellement
simple s'il n'y avait pas ces vagues qui
monte inexorablement
de plus en plus loin sur les terres nous
sommes au prêcheur petite commune
d'environ 1500 habitants ici 300 maisons
sont menacées par l'érosion dans le
quartier des abymes jojo en sait quelque
chose
depuis qu'il a repris ce restaurant il y
à 16 ans il ne cesse de subir les
assauts de la mer pour résister il a
lui-même financé cette enrochements
c'est mes propres moyens c'est du 25 mai
l'eau un autre au premier moyen donc
25000 euros par ci par là
pratiquement tous les deux ans on a des
dégâts d'eau et personne ne vire au
secours même les je dirais même allé
plus haut placé premières vagues étaient
à l'abri qu'à 45 m à lens belleville
donc le catch est juste après la mère
est rentrée de 75 m
voilà est précisément là où elle est
actuellement la mer c'est à ces endroits
là que se passait les fêtes les fêtes de
quartier il y avait des boutiques y
avait des boutiques dans le bourg
d'autres ont déjà dû baisser les bras
face à la mer le maire estime qu'une
cinquantaine de maisons ont déjà été
évacuées abandonné à cause du danger
imminent
il ya eu là où il ya eu la mer aussi
hein parce que nous on avait une belle
plage on avait un poulailler on avait un
cocotier des cocotiers maintenant on a
plus rien ouais il ya beaucoup de
tristesse là dedans c'est pour ça que je
viens pas souvent parce que bon chaque
fois que je viens c'est ça ça me fait
quelque chose qu'un parce que je pense à
mes parents ma famille mes frères et
soeurs on est assis heureux là dedans et
puis bon ben maintenant il n'y a plus
rien entre la mer et les l'art c'est
toute une partie de la commune qui est
donc appelée à disparaître
pour le maire pas le choix il faut
repenser la composition spatiale du
prêcheur doux l'inscription de la ville
à un programme inédit intitulé opération
d'habitat renouvelé en outre-mer l'idée
déplacer les populations vers les mornes
dans des logements séduisant et
respectueux de leur mode de vie entre
terre et mer pêche et agriculture des
logements construits dans des matériaux
naturels
c'est vraiment projet expérimental mais
il s'agit pas d' expérimenter pour faire
nous fait l'intéressant nous non il
s'agit justement de répondre aussi un
besoin de la population qui aspire bien
sûr à vivre de manière secure mais dans
des conditions de confort à laon c'est
vrai que quand on parle de bambou comme
papa le rouge ça rappelle les
constructions anciennes donc les gens
peuvent penser qu'on leur propose de
revenir à l'âge de pierre st jeu de mots
ma réalité c'est pas du tout ça au
contraire on peut s'appuyer
même si cette innovation on peut
s'appuyer sur des techniques
traditionnelles d'une part s'appuie sur
des matériaux qu'on utilisait étaient
adaptées à nos réalités climatiques et
bien pour une eau vais pour faire du
bâtiment moderne et confortable
après un concours d'idées nationale
quatre projets ont été retenus ici
le premier lauréat l'équipe tonnes qui
devrait intervenir au centre-bourg en
privilégiant les pierres du lard comme
matière première
le second lauréat l'équipe mythe propose
au quartier champ bolo un habitat
tourner à 60 70 % vers l'extérieur qui
favorise des matériaux comme la terre et
le bois deux équipes sont troisièmes
ex-aequo elle devrait s'intéresser à une
autre parcelle du centre bourg
l'équipe cause a créé une architecture
modulaire légère adaptable souple
robuste faisant la part belle au bois et
aux briques isolantes ans sargasses
enfin l'équipe atelier tangram a conçu
des maisons individuelles constitué
majoritairement de bois de bambou
de pierres et de terre à partir d' avant
la fin de l'année on va lancer toute
l'étape des procédures pour pouvoir
aller ensuite très vite dès 2021 sur des
premiers opérations d'aménagement et en
attendant en parallèle on lance des
prototypages ses modèles à l'échelle 1
des propositions des architectes
on va faire ce prototypage avec les
habitants et on va démontrer que c'est
possible
au total 100 à 145 constructions neuves
sont prévues dont la relocalisation de
l'école après ville le prêcheur avec ses
12 km de côtes fait figure de ville
pilote dans cette expérience inédite en
france
restera ensuite à séduire des familles
aux revenus modestes fortement attachés
à leur lieu de résidence